guten tag mein name ist tobias sei klar
der schlüssel ist bestimmt von fdp
was führt sie zu mir ja ich
[Musik]
weiß gar nicht was ich sagen soll ich
definitiv von der fdp ich bin
abgeordneter der fdp war das hätte ich
jetzt gar nicht gedacht ja setzen sie
verlegen sie sich hinreißen ganz schöner
knochenjob was eigentlich gar nicht aber
diese undankbarkeit der wähler also das
macht mir wirklich zu schaffen
wir machen doch als reine
klientelpolitik
und doch sind wir bei drei
landtagswahlen in folge abgedankt
ich verstehe das alles nicht also eine
geile partei als uns kannst du in
deutschland doch gar nicht kriegen total
realitätsverweigerung
bitte nichts sprechen sie ruhig weiter
ja ich meine wenn jemand in diesem land
irgendwas von finanzpolitik versteht
dann ja wohl wir von der fdp ehrlich
was nicht aufschreiben
also ich mache den job seit zehn jahren
aber manchmal bin ich immer noch
sprachlos
da liegt ja immer noch hier um
entschuldigung das macht er jetzt die
ganze zeit an da ja das ist der coach
von der spd
ja total am boden wie die ganze partei
denkt aber jetzt die ganze zeit wo
schulz kanzler geworden ist sagen sie
wieder eine ganz große nummer
als ob die leute aus überzeugung scholz
gewählt hätten
gäbe ihnen gut ja ich habe sie
versehentlich getreten ist ja eigentlich
der job ihrer partei menschen zu treten
die auf dem boden liegen
sie können gern liegen bleiben wenn sie
möchten aber dann bricht das natürlich
weiter
die gefallen mir aber das problem ist
halt dass wir bei den vielen krisen auf
der welt gezwungen sind schuld absolut
absolut ich finde auch dass die fdp an
allem schuld ist einsicht ist ein guter
erster schritt
nein schulden wir müssen immer mehr
schulden darauf nehmen egal worum es
geht spd und grüne schreibt überall in
der welt auf irgendeinen deckel an rufen
dann rotzfrech ist dann wird er bezahlt
so zu sagen dafür dass dann die verluste
getragen werden das ehrlich alleine 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr was hätte
man mit dem geld alles gutes tun können
beratungsstellen krankenhäuser hin
schuldenbremse schwarze null ich bin
ganz ehrlich ich glaube bei ihnen müssen
wir sowieso ganz von vorne anfangen so
was sehen sie auf diesem bild
geld also ein sehr sehr hohen betrag
geld okay gut und was ist mit diesem
bild hier da sehe ich jetzt
dass ich jetzt gar kein geld das ist ihr
das sieht aus wie
das sieht aus wie eine beule in meinem
kotflügel von meinem porsche die - und
geringverdiener ja mit seinem
verschlissene twingo rhein geschickt
hast ja da habe ich einfach nur vom
bäcker geparkt aber auf dem
behindertenparkplatz ach jetzt jetzt
nochmal hinsetzen wettkampf machen
weiter so was ist mit diesem bild hier
das ist einfach
lucas cranach der ältere in einem
porträt von doktor johannes schering dem
dompropst magdeburg und halberstadt
staunen sie interessieren sich für kunst
ich nein nein nein nein das ist nur
dasselbe motiv wie damals auf dem 1000
d-mark scheint ja den ersten die namen
meiner eltern geschenkt damals bei der
einschulung also mich erinnert dieses
unförmige schwarz-weiße immer an diese
wahlplakate von christian lindner wo er
im auto sitzt und telefoniert
jetzt erklärt sie nochmal bitte eins ist
doch alles so gut an mit unseren
lächerlichen 11,5 prozent haben wir uns
in den koalitionsverhandlungen auf
ganzer linie durchgesetzt wie kein
tempolimit keine steuererhöhungen keine
nennenswerten klimaschutzmaßnahmen also
all das was unsere wähler von uns
erwarten wir den verdammten tank rabatt
durchgesetzt ihr klientel politik geht
doch gar nicht autofahrer
mineralölkonzerne titel der adac aber
jetzt rufen alle plötzlich gibt weil wir
gehen jetzt ganz ehrlich ich gebe dir
gleich gar nicht
wissen sie was ich sage ihnen jetzt mal
was was ich alle männer sagen die von
ihrer angebeteten zurückgewiesen werden
und die sie trotzdem mit immer noch
zusätzlichen aktionen stocken suchen sie
sich ein neues opfer eine neue
beschäftigung der vorsitzende ihre
partei hatte doch eine wirklich sehr
gute idee was die rolle der fdp in der
republik sein könnte es ist besser nicht
zu regieren als falsch zu regieren da er
von der fdp gut regieren nicht kennt
kommt ja nur das andere in frage und war
soll das soll auch das kann auch keiner
so gut ausdrücken wie ihr chef christian
lindner für einen arbeitsplatz fällt weg
geh nach hause wir brauchen dich nicht
mehr also gehen sie jetzt bitte ihre
zeit das
ok
und wie verbleiben wird das regelt der
markt ach sie meinen das regelt der
markt nehme ich meine mag da sitzt da
ich mache die terminplanung
daran denken kein problem ist so groß
dass man es nicht ein zwei jahrzehnte
aufschieben könnte bis nächste woche
ihre probleme möchte ich haben hab ich
ja sogar merkels erbe aber machen sie
mal schön weiter er bewohnte termine